what up people
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for october
22nd 2020 and tonight
get ready it's the what should have been
third debate but it's the second debate
because they canceled the third debate
that's right 77 year old joe
biden versus 74 year old donald trump
who will lead us into the new world
we'll find out
uh yeah we got a debate tonight um we'll
see what happens we're going to get into
that
it's going to be interesting they're
changing around some of the rules
they just basically all make it up on
the fly pretty much anything they can
figure out to do to
to help biden the democrat obviously
they do
in this case they're changing up
something related to muting microphones
to stop interruptions it's all just
sort of silly tomfoolery in trickery uh
so we're gonna talk about that
and then uh quick reminder everybody i
will be live tonight
right here in this very room uh with
tequila i think we're gonna do it with
tequila tonight it seems like more of a
tequila night i've been doing the other
debates with whiskey but i think we're
going to do a nice sipping tequila
so we'll be live at 7 30 pacific that's
10 30 eastern time
and doing a live stream with the
reaction and we'll have some clips and
all that good stuff
and then right after that i'll be
joining uh glenn beck
on the blaze so if you ain't sick of me
you will be by the end of the day all
right so we're going to talk about the
debate
some some expectations what i think is
going to happen what i think
each one of these guys needs to do today
to accomplish and
and again it's all about just
the people who still haven't made the
decision those are the only people that
really matter
for a debate at this point we've got a
lot of people that know exactly what
they're going to do so they can
go oh i'm cheering for my guy or i don't
like that guy but this really is just
about can you move
anybody else through a debate i actually
do think
there are a certain amount a decent
amount i would say of people
that still can be moved but before we
get to all that
i want to talk to you about second
thoughts the game i've got it right here
in my hands people
second thoughts is the quick thinking
verse fast talking party game
second thoughts is this year's new
favorite party game that is sure to be a
hit
with your friends and your family on
game night it has been hit with my
friends i haven't seen my family because
of covid we're working on that
the play of the game calls for each team
to quickly create a list of words for
their opponents to decipher leading to
hilarious
puzzlement and laughter simply put it's
a classical word game
with a unique twist that allows players
to personalize the content with their
voluminous sense of word smithery
or just their witty and warped
imaginations each round of second
thoughts is a hilarious high-speed
attempt to stump the other team
both teams create a list of five things
using the letters revealed from the
colored dice
be witty and wise but don't take too
long because time is not on your side
the amount of time it takes your team to
create the list is exactly how much time
your opponents
get to guess them second thoughts the
quick
thinking first fast talking party game i
think i did pretty good there on the
fast talking part
and by the way guys the creators of
second thoughts are fans of the show so
that is how you can
show a little love to to people who are
putting some good stuff
out into the universe okay speaking of
putting good stuff out to the universe
the debate is tonight but before i get
to the debate i want to do one other
thing
i realized that i've been doing this
show for quite some time
about two months i've been talking
directly to you and obviously you're
spending most of your days
telling people how much you love dave
rubin and how great he is and the direct
message is amazing and the interviews
are fantastic and he's got the funniest
twitter and
all of those things but despite all of
that i i never
told you guys what my preferred pronouns
are so i don't even know how you're
referring to me and i assume in
in probably some offensive ways ways
that are that would be really upsetting
if i heard them so i want to just get my
pronouns out my preferred pronouns
so that when you tell people you love
that dave rubin you know exactly how
to refer to me so to be very clear my
preferred pronouns he
him lord count master prime general
commander and zbornak those are my
preferred pronouns
you can refer to me as any of those and
if you don't i will report you
to the proper authorities okay guys
let's talk
debate it's tonight as i said it was
supposed to be
the third debate it's only the second
debate because they canceled the middle
debate
after trump came down with corona and
although he was already healthy at that
point
they were going to do it over skype or
over zoom or
over these electronic pipes that we do
all this stuff through
but the trump side didn't want to do it
because they felt that would be giving
biotin an unfair advantage because he
could have somebody talking in the ifb
that's the earpiece
or he could be getting information off a
teleprompter or have people with cue
cards or anything else
so they backed out of it which you could
debate either way whether that was good
or bad i mean trump didn't have the
greatest
first debate right i mean even even his
most ardent supporters
he was a little too jumpy a little too
combative he also was debating two on
one for sure chris
chris wallace obviously uh is is going
biden
uh or at least leaning in that direction
and it seems like all these media people
every time they they try to be impartial
they seem to secretly
although not so secretly have to prove
to all of their liberal friends that
they're just not
really a scary republican right so they
always end up going more
against the republican and conservative
and you know
i've said this many times but that in a
weird way is the essence of the trump
campaign that
for for all time or at least in modern
times so let's say the last 50 years or
so
uh it's been the republican people think
it's the republican versus the democrat
but really what it is it's the
republican verse the democrat
and the media and if you think about it
i mean so think about it you had barack
obama
and barack obama and the media versus
john mccain who we were told
was a racist and uh you know hated women
and
the same thing it was barack obama and
the media versus mitt romney and
binders full of women and all of that
stuff trump is the one who said okay
i'll fight you guys
and i'll basically take you out as the
media so
in essence what has to happen tonight
here here's my my prediction oh and by
the way i should say
we will be live immediately after debate
the debate we might start a minute or
two
uh before the debate ends because i know
everybody's watching and then they
suddenly figure out where we're gonna
watch the post game wrap
up and then they're jumping around we
might start a minute or two early but at
7 30
pacific time we are here in crazy los
angeles
uh we will be going live right here on
the youtube uh and i'll be
going for about 40 minutes or so and
then i'm going to be jumping over and
talking to
glenn beck glenn beck on the blaze so
you can catch the wrap up oh and i think
i have to think about it throughout the
day but i think that i will be doing
this with a little sipping tequila
tonight i've done the other debates the
first presidential one and the the vp
debate
with uh with whiskey which i have
enjoyed and i think you guys have
enjoyed watching me drink it
but i think we're going to go with
tequila tonight something about tonight
since it's the last one
it reads tequila to me so i think it's
going to be a tequila tequila knight so
anyway make sure you're subscribed to
our channel and you click that
notification bell so that you can
see the live stream later and now allow
me to uh
lay out a couple things about the debate
so first off the debate moderator is
kristin
welker and uh from everything i can see
she's going to be
pretty nonpartisan except for and this
is exactly what i was talking about a
moment ago
her history well i'll read it to you she
was previously registered to vote as a
democrat but
since 2016 has been registered in
washington dc with no party affiliation
now
that doesn't necessarily mean anything i
i've told you guys
me here in california i'm registered as
a democrat not because i
am a democrat but because i wanted to be
able to vote in these past
primaries so that i could vote against
bernie sanders so i actually voted for
joe biden in the primaries because i
thought that bernie sanders was the
bigger threat now
the irony of that of course is that all
of the horrific ideas
of big government and taking whatever
you want from the people and giving it
to whoever else you want to give it to
that all is being imported through the
biden campaign but
uh you know it's coming from the bernie
movement and it's being imported through
biden right and vibin's just the shell
for the thing
um but i but i felt at least there would
be this semblance of
something sort of remotely close to an
old democrat if you got biden and i
still think that is
somewhat true but but barely true i just
thought biden would be better than
getting the full-on
grotesque socialist lunacy of
of bernie sanders and i think a lot of
people did that so so
the point of that though is that her
party affiliation doesn't necessarily
mean anything
she may have had her own considerations
but my guess is
she probably is more of a democrat than
a republican so that's one thing to talk
about
the topics for tonight are sort of
interesting and
uh and particularly interesting because
they're leaving one out that we have not
talked about at all and i think trump
really needs to bring up one way or
another tonight
the topics for tonight are going to be
coveted 19 obviously american families
not family guy american families race in
america because we don't talk about that
enough
climate change because apparently we can
fix the climate
we americans we can do anything national
security and leadership
now the one that's missing there and the
trump campaign is not happy about this
is foreign policy and this is this is
super interesting to me because
none of the debates the the first
presidential debate
nor the vp debate had anything to do
with foreign policy like it pretty much
has not been touched there's been a
mention of russia here or there
but but pretty much nothing and to me
this is a really bizarre one that the
trump people are letting slide because
he's ending the war in afghanistan right
at this point i think he said
that all of our troops will be out by
christmas uh there might you know there
might be a couple people left but
basically we're ending
the longest war in american history did
you know that
the afghanistan war which nobody is
really clear why we went into in the
first place
and has now been going on since what
since late 2001 or 2002
i mean basically an 18-year war the
longest war in american history is about
to come to a close that is because
of donald trump ending that war so
that's number one number two
uh you know you guys know i'm old school
and i
thought that one thing that everyone
agreed on is that we want peace in the
middle east
that seemed to be a good thing that we
wanted israel and the arab countries to
be at peace well
there were the abraham accords about a
month what was that two months ago now
and uh the uae the united arab emirates
uh and and israel are now
at peace they have a piece of paper that
says that they're at peace
this is a good thing there are all sorts
of rumors
that other countries will get on board
this and that the gulf states even if
they haven't officially said it
that there's no reason to think that
they're going to be at war with israel
there's trade already starting
i mean this is this is real stuff this
could reach saudi arabia
and it's it's a complete flip actually
on the way
everyone viewed the middle east that
you'd have to solve the palestinian
thing first but actually it's being
proven you can do it in another way
so that has a little something to do
with donald trump you would think he
would want to talk about that you would
think he would want to talk about moving
the american embassy to jerusalem etc
etc so the fact that they're doing
nothing on foreign policy here the fact
that he's got other countries
actually paying more of their fair share
on things
you might also want to talk about
foreign policy because
we should probably talk about that china
place right or china
as he calls it um so it's just very
bizarre that we're gonna go
through two presidential debates one
vice presidential debate
and we ain't gonna talk about foreign
policy at all so i i hope that trump
throws in a little something there um
because i think that's that's a win for
him it just
it just strikes me as a as a total win
so that's
that's something there uh but then
here's the key to this thing
and this is where the rules are just
changed it seems like we have nothing
anymore that is
consistent like you could wake up any
day and anything could be changed any
rule in the past can be changed in
anything else
well the debate commission has decided
to adopt
a new rule that they did not not have a
week ago
did not have two weeks ago or 20 years
ago to mute microphones
for this final event so basically when
the
question is asked to one of the
candidates they will have two minutes to
respond and the other candidate
is going to be muted for that now
clearly they're doing this to help biden
right like the thought process and i
don't think it's going to work but
the thought process obviously is
especially in the first debate trump was
very jumpy
and he kept interrupting and by the way
biden called him stupid and a racist and
all of that stuff too so they were both
doing it but trump was very jumpy
and the idea i think by the commission
is we've got to stop
trump from sort of taking over so that i
think was their intention
however where does that road to hell
come from where
what leads to it good intentions right
there well i don't think
these were good intentions but these
were their good intentions good
intentions
i think in essence what's going to
happen here is that trump made a mistake
i think in the last debate
by continually interrupting biden
because every time he interrupted biden
biden was
able to reset and biden seems to be able
to respond if you directly go at him he
can sort of reset and respond
the idea that biden supposedly off the
cuff
supposedly without pre-written
statements and not hearing anything
or not on adderall or whatever else
the idea that he can talk for two
minutes uninterrupted and makes sense
i think they're going to regret this it
seems to me that that would be the the
scariest thing for him at this point
that this is
this is the thing that he really can't
do so i think they did it to help biden
and i think they might find out that
that it's not going to help guide him
but even
putting that aside i think the the
broader idea here
is that these things are not really
debates you know i said it a couple
weeks ago but what
really would be better than than have
even having a moderator maybe you have a
person there just to occasionally move
it along
is basically say to the two of them okay
we've got these five
six topics you've got 15 minutes each
to to start talking about them and and
back and forth one can start and you got
you know you got like your two minute
opener
the other guy's got two minutes and then
and then if that's four minutes then
you've got nine minutes of back and
forth and just
let them do it just let them actually
argue and exchange ideas perhaps the
same way that you might when you're
talking about politics with people
i think that's part of why the the show
it feels like the show is sort of
breaking down doesn't it right
like we're at the end of when these
debates are going to make any sense
we're watching a 77 year old and a 74
year old
argue in canned prepackaged statements
and it's like you really
can't get that much new information
which also is why i just think that this
isn't
about the winners and losers in that
traditional sense that the media is
going to frame it tomorrow
and i assure you the media really really
wants biden to win this was not a good
week for biden first off
biden has had a lid on the campaign
since monday morning now
it's thursday today that means he hasn't
done anything public
since then uh trump's been doing rallies
thousands of people
out there there's this whole hunter
biden laptop story which now
has been confirmed by the fbi that it is
hunter biden's laptop
the new york post by the way which is
the newspaper it's one of the
longest-running newspapers in the hit in
the history of the united states
they have been locked out of their
twitter account as of me taping this
right now for
over six days because of putting the
article out there so this
this hunter biden story it's not just
about
hunter biden his connections to ukraine
how the biden family profited from it
and that joe biden obviously knew about
it in a in a weird way i'm sort of like
oh they're
they're politicians and they're all kind
of gross and they they all do this stuff
and how did biden get his big mansion on
his government salary and
like all that kind of stuff like i
expect them all to be corrupt
i expect every single politician to be
corrupt and use connections and and all
of those things
and and in a weird way anyone with that
much power including you watching this
probably would do something similar the
idea that you could get through the
system
to get all the way up to be a uh a vice
president
is is uh you know without being deeply
corrupt
is pretty crazy but you know what before
we do all that guys i want to talk to
you
about built bar okay how was that for a
transition
are you guys looking for a new protein
bar
that tastes like a candy bar well i've
got just the brand for you
guys built bars are super tasty and come
in 18 amazing flavors
my personal favorite is cookies and
cream i've got it right here
and it ladies and gentlemen is delicious
they're covered in 100
chocolate including both nut and nut
free flavors and are soft
and easy to chew with halloween just
around the corner it's easy
to slip up which is why bill bars are
the perfect alternative to candy for the
health-conscious guy
i can actually lose or maintain weight
while indulging in a delicious treat
built bars are low calorie
low sugar high protein and high fiber go
to bilpart.com
use promo code ruben people and you'll
get 20 off your first order use promo
code ruben for 20
off your first order at billbar.com good
for bar is built
go or build boost and now back to me
hello um okay so
we can whittle all this down i think in
effect to those people in the middle
right it's the people in the middle and
or you know what let me get back to i
was on a little biden tangent there let
me continue with that
this thing isn't about hunter biden and
access and all that now
there are legit issues there and as i've
been talking about in the dm for the
last couple days there are plenty of
mainstream
people that are trying to pretend it's a
hoax and all that the same people who
were pushing a russian hoax are now
telling you something
that the fbi is saying is true uh is
is a hoax because they don't like the
direction it's going in and and that
also goes back to this reality war that
i've been talking about it's like you
pick a side
you see things when you want to see them
and you don't think you don't see things
when
when you don't want to see them so that
that's one part of this but the idea
that the new york post has been locked
out of twitter for six days the idea
that twitter was stopping links being
from
uh being put up and then get this one
you know for those of you that are on
twitter
you're probably aware of this but for
those of you that aren't on twitter and
you're you're happier people and you're
better people
this is an important little little
tidbit that you should know about
even if you're not on twitter which is
that twitter just in the last like three
days they made it harder to retweet
so retweet obviously is when you just
see something you like you press the
retweet button and then it goes to all
of your followers as well
so the way this always worked or at
least for the last couple years
with twitter was that you could just
press a button and it would go that
would be a manual retweet or you could
do
sort of like a contextual retweet and
that you could press a button
you could add some commentary and then
also send out
that message well they decided just in
the last couple days to get rid of the
manual one so in effect
you have to basically press it twice to
send it out to your people without
adding comment
i know this sort of sounds like insider
nonsense and why am i even mentioning it
and why is that important
well we know that big tech is
manipulating us
at every level at every stage
consistently and constantly
so why is it that twitter has worked one
way
for years and literally two weeks before
an election they make it
harder or more confusing to send out
a message to amplify a message you
believe in so when i saw it on my phone
the first time i thought my phone
was having a glitch or something because
they also didn't even send out a message
i happen to see
that jack dorsey on twitter the ceo he
sent out one message about it but but if
you didn't see that and then you're
going wait a minute i can't retweet the
way i used to
you might not know that something's
there and the reason they're doing that
is they don't
want certain information to travel as
fast as
it can or it would with with you know
14 and now less days to an election
so i know that sounds like a little
insider baseball stuff but these things
are important so when you can't post
certain links
because twitter decides that you can't
and you can't post certain things on
your facebook speed because facebook
decides you can't
and they're they're telling us that it's
all because of the way things are
sourced
or what's true or we're going to put a
warning or the rest of it it's like
you guys are obvious liars and we we all
see it and we all get it and in many
ways
and i think this is what trump should
hit and hit it hard tonight
in many ways this is what trump is
running against more than biden biden
biden in effect is nothing uh like the
biden move the idea that there's like a
biden movement
or what does joe biden's democratic
party stand for it stands for nothing
what it
what it is is the placeholder for the
far left to come in right behind it even
if you look at biden's twitter account
now it reads
of just meaningless slogans that that
is very much what bernie's twitter
account has felt like for the last
couple years so they've completely
infected that thing
so if you're voting for biden it's like
you either don't know what you're voting
for or you're not getting what you think
you're voting for
with trump i think this thing this idea
that i'm running against the media but
now i'm also running against big tech
it's like that's real
that i just see that as real and you may
again you may not like trump and he uses
he uses a sledgehammer when sometimes he
could he could just
you know push something in with his
finger um but
that sounded weird when he pushes
something in with his finger he uses a
sledgehammer instead of just you know
tapping a nail
something like that um you may not like
that but there's a reason like you could
see what that reason is to vote for him
and that that brings me to something
that i'll
i think i'll probably close on for today
because i've been thinking this through
i've been sort of working this
this theory through in my head over the
last little bit and i've wanted to kind
of put it out there so i want you guys
to
you know hopefully hear this and think
about it for yourselves and let me know
what you thought
what you think about it uh and as i
always tell you you can jump in at
reubenreport.com if you want to engage
with me directly oh by the way during
the debate tonight
i will be live chatting at
reubenreport.com and you can download
our
ios or google play app if you want to
jump into live chat with me
um but but i will end on this thought
i've been thinking about something and
it basically it goes like this that
trump at this point
as crazy as it sounds this orange hair
plugged man
this corrupt new york city businessman
who's been around forever who was in
home alone too
and used to be interviewed by david
letterman and had a
reality show on nbc and now has been
turned into a nazi by the media
that in an odd way i think you can argue
that he's not only saving conservatism
but he's saving liberalism
this is a really weird theory here but
but hear me out on this so how is he
saving conservatism
well that's pretty obvious right like
with the judges that he's
putting on board with the economic
policy he has with the foreign policy
as i think most people would say he's
governing
in a more conservative way than he
himself probably
is right i don't think he's act he
personally donald trump
is probably as conservative as he's
governing so i think i don't have to
spend too much time on this i think most
of you understand that
that he is a modern conservative
and that he's governing as a
conservative so okay that's how he's
saving conservatism
and also i should also say that in the
face of critical race theory and social
justice and everything else
he's fighting against that because he's
trying to conserve
some of the traditional american beliefs
and patriotism and things of that nature
so that's
that makes him a conservative i think
that probably seems obvious to most
people
but now how is he saving liberalism well
liberalism
as you guys know as i've talked about
endlessly and then wrote a book about
and everything else
when i talk about the good remaining
liberals of of which there are not that
many anymore liberalism in its classical
sense in its true sense and when most
people said they were liberals
until the last couple years what they
meant was
they're socially liberal that you can do
what you want you can smoke what you
want
marry what you want blah blah and then
they meant some sort of
fiscally conservative that was sort of
the old school that was the blue dog
democrat
um that was that was what most that's
what bill clinton would have purported
to be
and most liberals were that's very
different
than the modern progressive that wants
the government to do everything
that is completely against free speech
right liberals are supposed to be the
ones force free speech the aclu when it
was a good organization
was a free speech organization the aclu
is now is now a bunch of leftist hacks
trump in a bizarre sense is saving
liberalism because
as i've talked about many times the
liberals don't know how to save
liberalism why are all the liberal
institutions crumbling well the liberals
who said ah
were tolerant and decent they let in all
of these bad ideas to their institutions
to harvard to yale to the
to big businesses and all the woke
companies they let all of these bad
ideas in
and next thing you know you've got
racial quotas at schools and racial
racial quotas on on company boards and
now
in bananas california you've got people
wanting to put racial
quotas on the amount of public officials
that we can put in these were the these
were the bad
ideas of the past that liberals used to
fight against well who's the one
fighting against those things it's not
the liberals just sitting around talking
about it watching their houses burn it's
actually donald trump who's getting
critical race theory out
of of the federal institutions who's uh
who got title ix
out of the colleges so i think you can
make an argument
that trump is actually the one saving
liberalism and
saving conservatism and i know it sounds
bananas and crazy
and it's like well he he's not a
traditional liberal and he's not a
traditional conservative and that sort
of is why this whole thing is so weird
and i don't even sit here
as a as a maga hat wearing anything i'm
just telling i'm just
telling you what i think and i think i'm
onto something there and i'll just say
one other thing which is
if if you basically are on board what i
just said there
if that if any of that made sense to you
well then think of the other version of
it so what is biden
saving right like what is what does
biden mean well if your idea is
that he's saving you're voting for biden
because i think a lot of people are
doing this they're voting for fighting
because it reminds them of something
before
trump right and i think there's there's
a certain comfort in that like oh maybe
the world could go back to that well
the base and the media and the future of
the democrats
they hate the old world they hate the
constitution 1619 project they hate the
founding of america
all of these things they're making it
very clear that the old ways were all
wrong and run by racists and everything
else
so that's why biden after 47 years of
being in government does doesn't make
sense at at any level because it's like
if if the
base is right and that everything has
been so wrong
well then biden was either part of it
and didn't do anything of it or he
helped cause it
so the idea that you're conserving
something by voting for biden conserving
just the way the world used to be like
that's not it
and then how is he also not saving
liberalism it's like if you think joe
biden
because i do think he's probably more at
his best
he's more of an old school liberal um
then i don't think he's like one of
these crazy progressives but he also the
other day said that you know when you're
eight years old you can decide to be
transgender i mean the guy just doesn't
know what he's talking about at this
point
if you think that he can stand up to
what the left
is importing you're just you're just
mistaken so in many ways
a vote for biden will be a vote to
accelerate the destruction of race
of racism you almost got me there people
it will be a vote to accelerate the
destruction
of liberalism and i just see it that way
i
i can't see it any other way but i i
would love to hear your thoughts on it
anyway guys
i got a long day of of interviews and
and doing other people's shows and a
whole bunch of other stuff
debate tonight we're going to be having
pizza
i think i don't know we're doing wings
tonight it is wing night at the reuben
report so i'll have some wing sauce all
over my face a little tequila for you at
7 30 pacific 10 30 eastern
i'll see you then and then glenn back
after that and then you know we'll see
if the world's still here tomorrow i
have a feeling it will be but we'll find
out
you